Merry Christmas Clara Godfather your  gift this year would be something you'll  never forget most people don't realize  there are troubled realms within our  world  [Music]  [Applause]  and you hold the cheese  to their secrets  remember Clara nothing is as it seems  where am I you're in the four realms  princess Clara  that's your service your majesty maybe I  have been spending too much time the  Attic welcome to our world  the land of snowflakes the land of  flowers and the land of sweets but in  the fourth round  is where our troubles began  mother ginger started this war don't you  know it's dangerous here I hope you'll  be the one to finish it it's time to  save the kingdom physics the does laws  always work Horace fine  ready  [Music]  she's gathering her forces you're the  only one who can stop her  I've been expecting you  it's time  you  [Music]  [Applause]  you